you know you hear a lot of people during
this season say things like influencers
will say things like you know don't wait
to new year to create a resolution I
don't believe in new year resolutions
because you ought to have resolutions no
matter what the time of the year is and
that it's true I agree with them but the
season is a season where a lot of people
are thinking about making new your
resolution so what does that mean to you
well I'm at the house right now relaxing
with the family we just came back from a
Cowboys game I got about 20 people in
town here and we'll spend a few days
together we'll have a good time
conversation camera mod leadership I
said look everybody wants to be a leader
because it's the highest position I said
yes I've said that many times but I also
believe everybody's a leader you're a
leader the boolean kid that bullied you
he's also leader the drug-dealer leader
I think every wants a leader the most
negative person on your family that
converts other people to be negative
that person is a leader the person I
convinced you to smoke with he's a
leader the person that convinced you to
give up on your dreams that person's the
leader the person I convinced you to go
watch a horror movie didn't feel like
watching a horror movie that person's a
leader everybody leads except the only
question is what are you leading people
to do you new year's here you got
resolutions what are you leading people
to do let me tell what I used to lead
people to do I used to lead people to
drink beer when I joined the army one
guy said you know let's see who can
drink the most beer one night and we sat
there and became a tradition 23 beers
and one night oh my gosh people were
hammered oh my that guy can hang he
drank 23 and he hasn't even thrown up
your dad solid Jukka beer bong how many
can you do these beer bongs a still
leadership it's just leading people to a
beer bong at Rosarita or Tijuana or all
that stuff I mean yes this is Patrick
with David I still lead people into
doing nothing I should leave people to
the gym eiseley people go play
basketball at RD why'd we go play
baseball sometimes hanging out sometimes
do nothing sometimes play Fester's quest
sometimes plays although sometimes all
that stuff is leadership
but most people lead people into things
that is just nonsense with very little
reward to it and generally it's
temporary reward if you're making any
resolutions for 2019 this will
my challenge - if you write it on a
piece of paper I would challenge you to
be a leader amongst other leaders who
are positively making an impact in the
world because if you were to ask
yourself right now well you know perhaps
making a point right now everyone is a
leader if I'm a leader meaning you what
have I been leading leading people to do
in 2018 huh did you leave someone to
quit or give up or turn against another
friend or an acquaintance what did you
leave people to do did you lead people
to read some books this year did you
leave people to work harder this year
did you leave people to not work that
hard this year but it's because you
don't want to work that hard and you're
afraid that other people may work hard
and pass you up just to really take
inventory right now look 2019 is not
gonna be any different everyone's gonna
write a bunch of resolutions down and
the only people that would literally
have a better 2019 than the 2018 are
those who are willing to be extremely
transparent with themselves very hard to
do most one do it only if you will do it
only if you matter of fact you see that
kid right there or is yet my middle son
the blue one just had a conversation
with him earlier today about leadership
top one we're at the cowboy scam when we
left wasn't an easy one but I had to
teach him how to talk to him
but the value leadership because my
goals in life the position I want to be
known for isn't it a doctor isn't a
doctor isn't a captain isn't a you know
sergeant or any of that stuff for me the
biggest compliment is when other leaders
who are positively making an impact in
the world when they say that guy
influenced me to do something I couldn't
do on my own that to me is the highest
level of leadership because in my life
other men and women who have done that
to me I think about them as a leader
that positively impacted this man's life
and a list is long list a long list I
challenge you to want to be on that list
for other people in 2019 oh by the way
it pays very well that's a fifteen
thousand square foot home tennis court
swimming pool I don't know how many
bedrooms four stories all the way up
there's like a cigar lounge with a bar
you relax you see the view of Dallas
over there eight car garage life is good
when you lead others to do things that
they wouldn't do on their own and as
long as it's positively leading others
to do something they wouldn't do on
their own anyways Merry Christmas Happy
New Year love you remember PVD loves you
take care bye bye